fabrice di vizio merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur un écran ce alors je
rappelle que vous êtes l'avocat du
collectif de médecins
kovy de 19 et de l'association des
victimes du corona b'rith en france vous
avez à ce titre a déposé une plainte
contre eux agnès buzyn et edouard
philippe alors pour commencer sur quoi
peut déboucher la commission denquête
qui entend aujourd'hui le professeur
raout absolument sur rien
la commission denquête n'aboutira à rien
j'ai suivi les travaux de manière
assidue et puis j'en ai eu marre j'ai
arrêté parce que en fait c'est un entre
soi politique
est-ce que vous avez vu la façon dont
ces gens répondent on n'est pas dans la
recherche de la vérité
on est dans une apparence de recherche
de la vérité c'est pas la même chose
jérôme salomon était chez lui on lui a
posé aucune question regarder on n'a
demandé à jérôme salomon que vous a dit
madame busin le 20 décembre elle dit
vous avoir alerté cause at elle dit il
n'a pas répondu à la question ça n'a
posé problème à personne
personne n'a répondu personne n'a relevé
moi j'ai demandé à ce que les soignants
d'un côté ce que les victimes de l'autre
soit entendu par la commission d'enquêté
parlementaire au madame bourguignon m'a
gentiment effectivement plus à l'est oui
mais manifestement m'explique-t-on elle
n'a pas envie de bousculer son
calendrier
voilà donc cette commission denquête
n'aboutira strictement à rien comme les
précédentes et à la prochaine crise ou à
la prochaine vague et bien nous aurons
les mêmes problèmes
alors quelle différence entre cette
commission denquête et la cour de
justice de la république devant laquelle
vous avez déposé plainte justement alors
la chronologie de république
d'abord est-ce une institution
judiciaire indépendante et la cour de
justice de la république elle n'est pas
là pour déterminer les causes d'un
dysfonctionnement de manière générale et
impersonnelle
elle est d'abord là pour établir des
responsabilités pénales
et si effectivement aux termes de l'
enquête il s'avère que l'un des
ministres et bien a commis une
infraction pénale ou si une étude de
l'avoir commis il sera renvoyé devant la
cour pour y être jugé mais la vraie
différence et comme pour le juge
d'instruction d'ailleurs comme allons
saisir
et bien c'est un fait que la cour a des
pouvoirs de perquisition allez pouvoir
de coercition et que quand on pose une
question un juge d'instruction ou une
commission d'instruction
on ne demande pas à genthod - pas gens
qui montent et on n'attend pas gentiment
la réponse soit la réponse est donnée
soit effectivement celui qui ne donne
pas qu avoir des problèmes ça s'appelle
l'institution judiciaire est donc la
différence et sans vraiment cinglante
notamment par les pouvoirs de
perquisition
où sont les bons de commande de masques
c'est quand le minimum que les avoir sur
quels faits précis vous avez finalement
saisi justement la cour de justice de la
république
aubin on a saisi la cause nationale et
public sur l'abstention volontaire de
prendre des mesures propres à lutter
contre l'épidémie précisément l'absence
de tests tout à l'heure dû dire à août
sera interrogé jeu j'attends avec
impatience cette audition parce que je
voudrais savoir comment un professeur de
médecine à marseille a réussi à lui tout
seul ce que l'état dans son ensemble a
échoué à faire et à dire que comment est
ce que j'explique que le professeur
raoul tu as été capable de tester et de
tester massivement
là où l'état sans démontrer radicalement
incapable on attendait ces réponses la
commission des requêtes
on les a toujours pas eu tandis que par
ailleurs j'attends effectivement qu'on
me donne les raisons pour lesquelles on
n'a pas commandé de masquer les
premières auditions de la commission
denquête font froid dans le dos à ce
niveau là parce qu'on montre
effectivement que personne n'a rien vu
venir que personne n'était responsable
et que au fond on avait tous des signaux
d'alerté concordants dont on n'a pas
tenu compte donc finalement à l'issue de
cette commission denquête les membres du
gouvernement ne pourrait pas être
poursuivie sur le plan pénal c'est ça
que vous nous dites également
ah bah c'est pas du de la commission
denquête le but de commission denquête
constitutionnellement il est clairement
celui de faire la lumière
dit-on sur des faits déterminés des
point à la ligne alors regardez les bons
de commande
apparemment j'ai appris qu'ils avaient
été demandés au gouvernement et la dgs
les bons de commande de masques ils ont
pas été fourni et ça ne pose problème
absolument personne vous voyez
effectivement si on n'a même pas les
pièces qui permettent de déterminer ce
qui s'est passé et qu'on a un refus du
gouvernement ou de la dgs de les donner
bah concrètement on va aboutir à rien
dans cette histoire c'est juste de la
politique politicienne
c'est pour donner l'illusion qu'on fait
quelque chose les députés se déchirent
les vêtements pour donner l'impression
qu'ils font quelque chose mais personne
n'est dupe
parce que tout le monde est responsable
et que faut pas se tromper gauche et
droite dans cette affaire sont
responsables de la crise parce que
l'impréparation elle décennale war multi
décennale et que tous les gouvernants
successifs ont leur part de
responsabilité et tout le monde le sait
merci beaucoup fabrice di vizio d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle que
vous êtes l'avocat d'un collectif de
médecins est une association de victimes
du coronavirus